choice architecture is about really
creating the environment that gives you
a good flow that's supporting your
well-being yes because any any setup in
the environment is already a choice
architecture whether it's a good one on
that one it's just that we need to be
mindful that anything you know if I have
some healthy snacks here I'm gonna eat
it if I have some unhealthy snacks here
I might also end up eating it that they
are triggering our decisions as 70% of
our decisions are very much guided by
auto piloting it's not so reflective and
that we need to be responsible in in
being my father influence yeah
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Sock'em we're on site
at the beautiful transformative
technology conference for our second
partnership with them we're now going to
be speaking with dr. ting jump I think
thank you for coming on our program yeah
and the perfect outfit for the program
as well I love it yeah yeah I do colors
colors flowers that's a nature yeah yeah
always
yeah I have the leaves you have the
flowers so fun for this before we get
into all of your stuff that you're doing
let's talk about are we really all one
right we're two people here so don't
tell me what you meant by Owen that's
your job to tell us what my question
means to you what do you think what do
you think I'm curious to hear about your
face my answer is yes okay
why so my answer is no why you're why
first we all come from the same source
we all have two sides of things but it
all comes from the same source
having to size doesn't mean that we have
to necessarily be one ok can we move I
like where you were going with this
though why do you bring up having two
sides to the same thing it's interesting
so for a long time we have been very
curious about why people resist
behavioural change and I think one key
barrier is failure so when we
acknowledge that we want to change we
also acknowledge that we are not yet
perfect and and that's really hard
right so the I think the two sides of
things allow us to be always a bit more
open to you know failure also means that
you can learn you can grow so it's not
just one way to look at it like there's
always this two ways and and I think
human flourishing is about growth it's
not about where you start with it's
about how you can you can grow over time
and it's important that we are open to
different perspectives I'm impossible I
would love to say you know multiple
perspectives but but at least starting
with choose is great because it balances
classic Gihon and young very tough
because you're right you we start off
with wanting to think this is absolutely
perfect this is the absolute Dow this is
exactly where it's supposed to be yet we
also want to say that we're flowering
we're in the process of blossoming
there's always room for improvement
we're always growing this is the point
of creation is the process of evolution
and also in the Chinese saying
you have to be when you are really in
the position of peeking up you have to
be mindful that that's not gonna last
for long or that's not the only side of
the story right and then when you are in
at the bottom you feel like you know
it's almost the end of the world you
understand that it's also the upside for
that for that journey so I think that
that's sort of you know being aware of
the counterfactual and also the other
side and being aware of the dynamic yeah
it's great now have you had feelings of
deep profound interconnectedness or ego
loss or unconditional love or des
presents tell us about your experiences
with that there was this moment in life
where it really changed my perspectives
when I was in Kenya I was visiting the
slum and of course you know bye-bye
appearance you can notice the colors
difference in all that sand but I felt
home in Africa which was really weird
and there was this little kid so I flew
in from Amsterdam I had this touch
cookies and I was you know of course
walking around and feeling really sad
for how terrible their situation is
without you know access to clean water
everything sturdy they were in poverty
and I was just sharing my little cookies
with with the little kids and everybody
was happy but there are two things that
shocked me one is everybody didn't want
to take a second bite they would share
after they take the first bite I only
had like two I wasn't prepared like
really like just two small cookies up
wow what a protocol so so as soon as you
take the first bite they they try to
bring the other kids they try to share
then there was this little
who rejected my cookie because he didn't
have time he was carrying he was the
five-year-old he was carrying a water
just taller than his knees okay he had
to take a break every ten steps because
it was too heavy
and he looked at me and he smiled and
then he picked up his water and he
walked on he didn't take the cookie and
at that moment I don't know I was I was
I was touched by you know how often I
felt I was having a hard time okay
sometimes you were like oh gosh this is
hard this is tough but knowing how
privileged I was I mean being able to
see the conscience and and being able to
say okay you know I was born so lucky
and they were born unlucky but yet you
know they persisted and they were still
so optimistic about life so or maybe
people in Metropolis are born unlucky
and people born in wilderness are born
lucky
yeah pending on how you view it right so
yes so there's wealth not just in money
and there's lots of other dimensions to
wealth this is a very interesting story
when were you in Kenya this was two
years ago years ago yeah Wow and this is
this is also very interesting because it
gives you that same thing that you're
talking about these like multiple
perspectives on given situations is like
try and get behind knives of someone
that's trying to like carry water
probably to their family or someone that
is was born with this idea that you take
a bite and then you pass it I can't be
happy if you're not happy so why would I
ever take this cookie and try and then
sell you half of it or whatever the
other philosophies are or like all then
we're indigenous tribes still go and
whoever whichever tribe comes back with
whichever family comes back with the
hunt shares it with the rest of the
tribe rather than tries to the questions
always asked well why don't you go and
and and store the meat and preserve it
and instead or the or the what you've
what you've got
well because uh the best place to store
it is actually in your stomach and my
friend's stomach yeah so if you come
back to the question are we won I think
I felt there one there but the sad thing
is the world of the poor the world of
the rich in whatever dimensions right in
health being wells in spiritual it's
it's it's in some way not one at the
moment yes we are divided and the
question is why and how can we put them
together yes um so I ended up you know
doing a lot of behavior interventions on
them because I felt deep inside us maybe
we felt they were different but they are
so much the same and when I brought a
ball game that was supposed to help them
overcome myopic you know decision-making
tendency the first time when they played
it if never played the game in their
life it's not like us you know we play
games all the time we train ourselves
you know we all kinds of supportive
materials they started like they
couldn't do strategic thinking they
couldn't think multiple steps ahead of
that they couldn't even strategize
within one round you know let alone you
know a few rounds ahead of time but then
the second time when they come back I
was shocked they were strategizing like
crazy yeah they were they were growing
like you know and and when we looked at
them and when we wanted to help I think
a lot of time we have out of warm grow
thinking that we you know out of
charitable feeling out of empathy but
really I think we need to help them out
of respect out of respect of the
potential human potential creating
demand sort of more like invest in like
it's wasted that's this person could
could become Obama this person could
become you know somebody wonderful doing
a lot of amazing things for the world
and which is not making the best use of
it at the moment and it's the cheapest
way to invest you know because even just
a little bit of help there they could
they could yeah they could get out of
poverty and just take a very different
path so I'm very interested in even well
as we're talking about this what is the
most upstream route of the big issue
that you also hinted at earlier where
this there's this disconnect between
what's happening in the metropolis is
and what happened indigenously with and
I and I do think that it's
interconnectedness I'm curious to hear
if you think it is is it is
interconnectedness is these feelings of
unity of oneness are they what's missing
in our metropolis as are they the thing
the the the idea that we are there is
separation is that the most upstream
issue of our world today if we look at
well-being I think if you look at the
top 10 causes of death of developed
countries versus developing countries
you see chronic illnesses my heart
attack cancer and a lot of these can be
prevented and and cure with better
lifestyle lifestyle change and if you
look at lifestyle one key factors stress
and if you look at stress one key remedy
actually is social connectedness so
loneliness it's terrible for fall stress
but being being able to have a social
groups with social supports it's
wonderful and if you look at loneliness
like how big is the problem if you look
at suicidal rates
what's you know what's the trend I do
think that we have a fundamental problem
of coming back to the the fundamental
human need we think about what makes you
happy
a lot of times even having a good social
connection a social relationship being
able to have a good love relationship
can make you so happy
but if you have a fight with your
colleague at work it can make you want
to quit your job right so and all the
time like when we're stressed about how
not meeting deadlines it's because we
feel bad not meeting the expectations of
other people yeah we're intrinsically
social where we're so in yeah we're such
as humans human species is a social
species so so I do think that it's it's
something that can give us a lot of
satisfactions life satisfactions
where we might overlook how important we
might underestimate how important this
yes yes you were hinting at this a
little bit ago we can dive deep into
this this is fascinating you use this
word choice architecture with me earlier
you were talking about myopic thinking
so extremely nearsighted I just want
instant gratification or rather than
maybe long-term goal-oriented thinking
strategic chest style 12 moves down the
line thinking this is fascinating feel
to many people we talked about this on
the show quite often what are uniquely
blueprinted for what is the gift that
you can bring to the world how do you
strategically bring that gift to the
world
but at the same time Arendt isn't there
like just just being what about just
being like if if if it is just that I
don't like the you know maybe it is just
maybe it is I don't want to learn more
about your choice architecture because I
just want to just be in the middle of
nature in the middle of my tribe out in
the wilderness or whatever it be so
choice architecture works or maybe
extremely like goal oriented trying to
bring something into the world but to
teach at least that that exists could be
like the point is like hey this exists
if you're interested but at the same
time maybe people that have super
goal-oriented need to learn how to just
chill the [ __ ] out and be and said you
know how do you feel about that what
makes you want to be just in a middle of
the nature
why does that count as being and not
like being next to you being among other
people is that not being your you're
right that it is also being but this
style of being has agenda and the other
style of being has no agenda okay so
people don't drink enough water is
essential for life so we have some
agenda about needing to drink water to
live you can say well let it be I'll
just not drink enough water I can let it
be but it's also not terrible if we
drink enough water and actually can feel
more when we're being ourselves we have
enough brain power to be mindful be more
mindful when we rest well when we sleep
well we're so much more relaxed and and
yes there's a agent that should be to
sleep better but but I think it's not
incompatible right with the concept of
the being so I think choice architecture
a lot of time it's actually about taking
away some of the decisions that are
really not that fundamental for you to
reflect on to spend a lot of energies on
because it's like Google Calendar help
you know when you're up for certain
appointments we can memorize it
ourselves but we don't need to write and
then it frees up your cognitive capacity
to really think about meaning of life to
really be sure sure right so so I it's
not necessarily bad of course and also
there's the again that's kind of the
same first principle of upstream
question around why even use that in the
first place regarding just needing
planning whatsoever
having no agenda whatsoever just being
in the state of constant
interconnectedness with the experience
of conscious and
yeah um I I find this conversation to be
really interesting but it's also I find
what you're doing to be extremely
important because you're showing people
that if you have something that you feel
like is a gift that you want to bring to
the world if you are uniquely
blueprinted to some to bring even some
sort of a butterfly effect style change
around the flowering of consciousness
over time then having 12 moves ahead of
time framing or offsetting some of your
cognition to Google Calendar Evernote
blah blah blah is actually extremely
useful for your productivity and for
your ability to bring that gift forward
and yes maybe mention that we do like to
increase the flow moments of human
beings because that's when they feel
really well right immersive being
immersive in in life and choice
architecture it's about really creating
the environment that gives you a good
flow that's supporting your well-being
yes because any any setup in the
environment is already a choice
architecture whether it's a good one on
that one it's just that we need to be
mindful that anything you know if I have
some healthy snacks here I'm gonna eat
it if I have some unhealthy snacks here
I might also end up eating it that they
are triggering our decisions as 70% of
our decisions are very much guided by
auto piloting it's not so reflective and
that we need to be responsible in in
being my fault that inference
yeah and in order to create sort of the
the better human experiences what what
are the most important things for
example for when I do want to bring
something that I'm uniquely blueprinted
to bring to the world or a gift that I
want to bring to the world what are the
things that you're seeing and studying
in choice architecture this is at the
Center for Advanced hindsight yes at
Duke what are you guys finding as like
these most first principal things
there's a great question
I think creativity getting people to get
into a creative mode it's something that
of course it's it's everybody would be
unique in those moments so you can try
to Cray you can for example blocking
time so we're starting to make Friday a
non-work you know today I mean it's it's
not that unique because everybody's not
doing it right but it's no cell phone
Sunday in itself is your choice
architecture okay in a sense of like it
blocks the time for you to connect or
uversa time for you to go for your deep
work do not worry about the the typical
kind of work yeah so give us more of
these these are very cool what else oh
we have maybe I can write yeah yeah show
us we love these yeah we love we love
demos on the show I love all right you
know what personal trait do you have
that annoys your coworkers
okay we we got a show okay let's see
these okay hold on all right all right
Oh conversational decks oh all right no
small talk knows I love that rule no
small talk okay everyone ready and okay
so what does that say what are you
embarrassed about so that's an
interesting question what law what else
do we have here ooh
this is a good one what personality
trait are you most proud of
okay Oh what do you value most in
friendship interesting so take us down
yeah why who do you like more your mom
or your dad
ooh oh yeah and it's like what's the
most touching gift touching or inspiring
gift have you ever given to someone oh I
love this yeah this is so good and you
know the questions I give them for my
best friend no house
but I actually didn't know the answer if
I have to get ya so I think it's it's
kind of the new kind of products feature
or products or architectural space
design that would trigger this all of
these good habits and good rituals that
we can have to get to know each other
more to be more in a moment to be more
productive to be more creative to be
anything that is less robotic yeah
interesting so Ken can we use
interventions like conversation decks to
break through small talk get to the
depths of the psyche get to these
questions that we maybe have never even
thought of answering ourselves so like
interventions like these are actually
really paramount for us trying to to do
things like a better understand who we
really are at the depths of the psyche
and also try and and guide ourselves
more towards what we can potentially be
uniquely gifted for that we didn't even
know was in our blueprint what what are
the other interventions these are these
are great so so far we have conversation
decks we have what was the first one as
well that you mentioned
oh no no no typical Wi-Fi day that we
now have yeah the no work Fridays yes
yes I recently picked up a ritual with
my mom to share the three things that
I'm most excited about for my day like
to just something that brought me sort
of deep meaning and joy and I was
surprised to find out you know to learn
about hers since I have lived abroad for
20 years now so we have you know with my
mom we would call you know once a week
but I don't get to experience her life
you know in the daily basis
and also sharing something just positive
right and it's and every time when I
reflect on my day I realized the kind of
things I'd like to share with her and
write about it I'm joyful about it's
actually not those that I would guess
that would be the one on top of my mind
that are too much work related or right
like there are moments where I'm
connected with another person or even a
stranger I was like oh that was actually
a very wonderful moment something worth
memorizing and remembering and and same
for my mom so I think even just with now
we have been doing it for a week we just
recently started I felt so much deeper
connected with her what a beautiful
ritual yeah yeah interesting
okay so then um I guess a good amount of
what you're doing is figuring out how to
design do you guys crowdsource these
ideas do you like having people submit
their rituals and you guys analyze them
to see how much it helps with well-being
I do think that that would be a really
great idea to close us we haven't done
that and if you have a way to help us to
cross those that we would love to get
suggestions that's why we do this show
play we play these games of tennis we
come up with good ideas and then we tell
everyone that's watching hey so we have
a link in the bio below you guys can
submit your I ritual ideas there was one
that was shared with my friend Mickey
who was found of Maya design who tried
this in the workplace that you asked
everybody to bring something a little
bit personal to what place and they
would misplace it and you have to fly
like yeah yeah what do you find
we find like toilet paper in the middle
of the hallway or something yeah yeah
you find like you find like a little
like like a little like toy of some sort
or a little item of some sort from like
a given culture in the middle of
somewhere it's not supposed to be in
like in the kitchen in the sink or
something and you have to like find and
know who it could be at the workplace
that actually owns that item yes that's
a cool game I love that game because
then you have to get to know people
better but it would also be that
everybody has to go and at least find an
item not like one person's going and
like playing the game and everyone else
is just everybody gets an item on their
desk and this item doesn't belong to
them oh yeah oh it's on their desk oh I
thought it was like you can go place it
anywhere in the workplace and wherever
you find a random item okay it's more
controlled in that sense small control
oh so then everybody has to participate
I like that okay yeah oh that's
interesting right
okay I like that one do you have any in
your life let's think I mean some of the
means some of the first things that come
up for me are just rituals of giving
what is available when people come in as
like guests into the home for the show's
just always wanting to you know to be
hospitable in some way and just give
whatever you know there's this culture
around the world that I forgot which one
it was that if someone points at
something when they're visiting and says
oh that's very beautiful they just give
it to them right away
so I guess my answers I would need to
spend more time analyzing myself this is
hard to try and compress my life into
something that I have some sort of a
ritual like what you were describing but
there are likely some that I could that
I could pull but hard to do so right now
that help you
few more presents just the deep depths
into the interconnectedness of all and
that usually just comes from a
meditation yeah it's a very
contemplative it's very meditative it's
but it's also deeply scientific it's not
just spiritual to me it's marrying the
two sides of the same coin so I
constantly think about the
interconnectedness of everything on a
scientific level as I do on a spiritual
level so and when I you know think and
feel and experience that feeling that to
me is I guess thanks for bringing that
up that's probably my best ritual but
it's such a personalized one there's
other people that I practice this ritual
with like the co-producer of our show or
II um he's someone that I practiced this
ritual with on just like us sometimes
we'll just be so meditative eat together
and he's just so meditative II himself
that I get triggered into the
interconnected state just by being
around him and stuff like that so the
more that someone in a sense is
unconditional love II and present thee
and etc the more you get vortexed into
that yourself but when you're such a
future builder that's what I'm so ops
and architectural II oriented that I
spend a lot of my time actually building
that future world and that's a hard
thing to figure out
yeah exactly like like like I guess I I
don't necessarily think that the future
can be built by just meditative feeling
and yeah yeah but some people counter
that point and they do say that you can
actually just be super present and
they'll build it and I'm like I'm still
trying to figure that out but go ahead
yes you're saying yes think about the
workplace
lots of people spend you know eight
hours missing at the workplace right
that's that's a lot I've after taking
out like sleep hours and all of the
necessary you know things you do with
your time
what's like what's the best way to
design office like forget about how they
are designed now how would you design a
workplace in a different way that you
would promote the most aggregate
well-being of everybody in there yeah
yeah I love this question we actually
just talked about it on an episode with
Brandon just a little bit ago on showed
earlier today where we gave the example
of if the if we were architecting our
our built environments with the first
principle of interconnectedness there
would be much more natural light there
being much more plants animals it would
be like basically if you took like
computational modernity and brought it
into the middle of force and beaches and
stuff like that yeah that's what we came
up with yeah and and as a as a scientist
I I would start with diagnosis of what's
the biggest contributing factors to
people's well-being during the day and I
would actually say taking a daily nap
could be very helpful for their mood
more than having plants around now plans
might be necessary but if you would
measure the impact of like how much
that's it how much do you feel satisfied
about life and if I would compare the
two interventions having 10 plants
around him or getting him to take a
daily nap I would bet on the daily nap
in that particular outcome yeah right
life satisfaction or mood yeah or even
house outcomes yeah interesting now how
do you get people to take it in now we
have some tech companies who are
actually endorsing this ideas but did
they approach in a scientific way of
like in order to make 80 percent of
their employees acquire napping habit
what do you need to do how do you need
to design your space how do you need to
design the the napping facilities so
that they actually do that it's not a
simple question it's not about just
having some napping rooms around because
people might not do it we always know a
behavior
it's more than just you know offering
the product right what about retention
maybe they tried the first few days and
then they drop out yeah yeah what about
an image social image social norms do
you need to intervene something right so
that becomes the two sides of these this
is yeah actually it's full circles as to
what we were very initial e talking
about which is when you are given this
super goal-oriented behaviors versus the
just take a nap let your let your body
like this relax during that internal in
entering internal world and in the
external world right it's the two the
two and they both need to come together
to support yes and external well I think
can be more scientifically designed
almost like the environment as medicines
for for supporting you like you know
that it's a good idea to take a nap but
you need or you know that you know
having more vitamin or whatever itself
but you still need to take that like
they need to be available for you so
another quick example is work break like
in between your you know tense meetings
etc break is amazing for productivity
now how do you make sure that people
take that five minutes break with the
most relaxation yes they need it's not
easy to be like just sitting around
having seeing all of your colleagues now
with the open space concept yeah you
don't have any privacy you don't you
can't just like you know shut down for
five minutes
right so we might end up then - just
checking social media so one thing that
we were brainstorming with our
architects in China is can you create an
enclosed pathway to the toilet because
you take you know you take toilet break
and they happen to coincide with your
work break mm-hmm so if I make it in
close if I play meditative music in this
inclination oh right I can decorate it
with all the green you want and nowadays
you know even green color sometimes
substitute I mean you cannot replace
plants ideal latest plants but if you
want a low-cost version right and you
let them walk back from the toilet as if
they walk back from a forest walk try to
simulate stuff like that stuff like that
it's not it's it's fully compatible with
you know your then you have the
multiplier effect so you have the
environment yeah you have the intention
of course you still need to work on the
self-awareness it's crucial yeah but
then it's you to to part of the puzzle
yeah yeah interesting this is given the
the limitations that we have today to be
able to make the interventions right now
that was that was a good example okay
and then I must ask you this because you
know we just came back from doing
interviews in China we love the
philosophies of the East the
philosophies the West are somewhat
different the two sides of the same coin
marrying is very important how do you
feel about how to best collaborate
geopolitically in the US yeah that's so
interesting I think the world you know
it's so difficult it's so easy to like
someone whose things like you it is not
easy to like someone who disagree with
you by by nature like we are all in
group oriented and sometimes were we're
still having our tribal instinct so
there's the effect call home awfully
affect if I find out that you were born
in the same day or there's certain you
know similarities all of a sudden I
trust you more it turns out there's an
experiment if you tell them like hey you
to actually share you know the same
fingerprint and it's rare it's not
common I'm much more likely to help you
out with a favor that you ask
afterwards right so but the the beauty
of mortality is about going beyond this
tribal instinct of liking you're in
growth and it's about having that
universal love I mean the economy of
impersonal exchange and having trust
with all of these changes I mean it
makes all of these wonderful beautiful
things happen and make the entire human
species as one as soon as you put it so
how can we learn from I think you know
how can we marry two different cultures
I think if we would practice if we would
find out some good tricks to even get
ourselves to like people with different
opinions people will not like us I think
we will be getting closer to think about
cultural collaborations yeah I like that
a lot yeah that was a great way to put
it
do you think that humanity is a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence so I mean it's it's such an
amazing whoa that we live in now with
all of the technologies making so many
things possible I was I cannot help
thinking about this metaphor about the
hammer and nails I think for one I think
humans are the one deciding what now the
hammer should be hammering on and we
need to have the intelligence to know
what we want the wall to look like well
what what what do we want to you know
put on a wall and which nails to hammer
and instead of just sharpening our
hammers I think we have enough shovels
it's important as well but I think what
we are lost losing side of is some of
these more fundamental questions and I
think even some of the questions like
meaning of life it's true that we cannot
be accurate about it but it doesn't mean
that having an inaccurate non precise
answer
is not important for us to have an
answer and it doesn't mean the fact that
we cannot be fully quantifiable right
and and I think there could be some
indicators that can at least be proxies
good foxes of that a being able to track
progress towards those fundamental goals
and it's crucial for us to be you know
keeping our idle control or confidence
above the digital world so yeah so I
think the emotional intelligence it's
yet to be I think the we certainly can
outsource our IQ anything that it's just
about you know computation and the other
kind of intelligence we we don't need to
be mastering those but we need to be
mastering EQ and then what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in creation
some of the most beautiful things tend
to be also the most intangible if you
think about love if you think about art
and the world do pay attention to and
our attention to get John to
quantifiable factors so I don't have in
concrete definition but I do know they
tend to be things that we would that we
can feel you know deep inside our hearts
and that we cannot explain why we feel
so in all with it
yeah yeah yeah
see I feel so excited and lightened
thank you so much for coming on our
program Thank You Allen thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below and the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also check out the links in the bio
below this is again the center for
advanced hindsight at Duke University
you can find that link in the bottle
below also other links to things work as
well also check out the links in the bio
below to the transformative technology
conference you can find all of those
links in the bio below you can check out
the links in the bio blow to our show as
well support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders and your
communities that you believe in you can
find our Pay Pal patreon cryptocurrency
link as well as our design cool merch
and get paid all those links are below
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
you
[Music]